[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful bone head of the
week B head of the week yes so nice I
see people in the chat asking about
little voice of John Kennedy Whispering
it's been a minute hey
y anyway thought i' give people thought
thought I'd give people that they've
been I saw people asking for in the chat
here well you know unfortunately John
Kenny is not going to be joining us on
bonehead of the week we have
representative George Santos we have
Tommy Tu branches tuberville and then
the dumbest of the trumps Eric Trump on
the list for bone head of freaking IDI
what an idiot an idiot
loser all right where should we start
should we start with George Santos I
think we should start with old Georgie
Porgy
umos Georgie Porgy actually you know I
have to admit we put him on bonehead
because he was voted on to be expelled
but Democrats are like no you're not
gonna do that [__] no no no no no no
you're not GNA get rid of him now now
that you guys have known this [__]
forever there was like 36 Democrats that
voted to keep that no 32 there was a 32
32 Democrats are like nope you're
staying right where you're at they own
you they're they made the Republican
Zone which I think is fantastic I think
yeah there there's also like okay so I
want to address something because I saw
some people in the chat we were talking
about yesterday I feel like and then I'm
sure other people online are like wait
what the [__] I want to find out who
this 31 people the 32 people are it's
like yeah you could find out who they
are and if you feel like you know you
want to vote against them or you know
get them primary whatever but um I think
people need to realize that you know
Rasin gave a good response which was
explaining why it would set a precedent
that would not be good and and did he
put that on video it's on video it's on
Twitter uh okay I'll see if I can find
yeah yeah so like Rasin answered the
question of like it would set a terrible
precedent for here we'd go more tit
fortat because we have to remember that
this whole censure situation was like
the censure that was in the resolution
to censure marger Taylor green was
actually introduced by balant back in
July and the reason they decided to
table it and not even bring it to the
floor was because they felt after they
censured Adam Schiff that it was going
to be a Tit for Tat and remind you that
Adam Schiff the reason he was censured
was because he was he played a role in
investigating Donald Trump so they were
coming back at him
for uh for you know just payback a TI
for Tat now censure you remove yourself
this doesn't really remove you from
Office you still have your seat you
still technically have voting rights
onot [__] but
anyway they table that in July and then
marger Taylor green was like well I'm
going to go after Rashida TB and then
Balon was like all right fine well I've
had this thing on the on the Shelf this
whole time I'm going to bring it back
out and then she went through 40 plus
examples over the last five to six years
of maror Taylor green saying the most
vile incendiary comments and being like
if there was ever an example of someone
who should be censured and should shut
the [__] up it's maror Taylor green so
then this vote happens with
George Santos and the censorship of
Rashida Talib and people were like oh
was this a deal that was made like did
they say like we won't if you vote not
to censure then we will vote not to uh
to expel there's that argument some
people think that it was just based on
the idea
that it was not to create a more another
Tit for Tat like you do this I'll do
that to get back you type of situation
and the other one of course tied to that
is creating a bad precedent when when he
hasn't actually been uh convicted or
when he hasn't actually been or you know
uh you know convicted or sentenced uh or
the Ethics Committee hasn't come back
with an actual report so which is
supposed to be happening by the way
November 17th so two weeks I think is
when the Ethics Committee is supposed to
be coming back with a report on George
Santos and their recommendation for how
to handle him so here's rasen's
statement on the screen here he says I'm
a constitution guy the house has
expelled five people in our history
three for joining the Confederacy as
traitors to the union and two after they
were convicted of criminal offenses
Santos has not been criminally convicted
yet of the offenses cited in the
resolution nor has been found guilty of
Ethics offenses in the house and interal
process which is what you were talking
about there this would be a terrible
precent descent expelling people who
have not been convicted of a crime or
without uh internal due process you know
this goes back to the 14th thing that I
was talking about and have been talking
about that you know they're trying to
14th Donald Trump in Colorado uh Jamie
Rasin probably agrees with me a little
bit about the 14th thing if he agrees
with this that you shouldn't be
expelling people are you saying four
teeth Donald Trump has four teeth four
well I mean I don't he probably wears
Dentures so I'm I'm guessing he doesn't
actually have teeth Fort for teeth
well John Kennedy definitely only has
four teeth that's how that's why he
whistles he's talking through his four
teeth um but no 14th 14th Amendment oh
oh 14th got it okay 14 14th the 14th
commandment well some might think it's a
commandment some think it's it is a
commandment like Glenn kishner thinks
it's a commandment but it's not a
commandment it's part of the
Constitution and that part of the
Constitution has not been tested on a
presidential ballot in a state like
Colorado where the secretary of state
would leave him off the ballot because
they don't like what he did not that
he's been convicted which Jamie Rasin is
pointing out here with George Santos
this would be a terrible president
descent expelling people uh who have not
been convicted of a crime without or
without internal due process if and when
Santos is convicted of these serious
crimes and offenses and ethnics charges
which back to the 14th um problem and
Trump I will certainly vote to expel
until then it's very RK
road to go down and we have to stick to
due process and rule of law as obvious
as the individual results
seem I can think of four or five
Democratic members the Republicans would
like to expel without a conviction or
adverse ethics findings we can't abandon
due process and the rule of law in the
House of Representatives so jam you're
asking makes a really good point there
now my point of why democrats should
vote to keep George Santos is just to
hang him around Republicans neck of look
hey look George Santos he's one of those
Republicans cuz he likes to lie a lot
he's kind of like a like a charm
bracelet you know just add him on you're
like oh I got my bigot my white
supremacist my Maga extremist my
domestic and my froster you know every
time they just throw on a new charm
bracelet on there the magga mega charms
Mega charm Mega charm bracelet that
seems to be something too speak speaking
of phrases I've got a little bit of uh
pixel crack here for the audience here
is here's the uh the Cheeto chicken
nuggets they just look like Cheetos but
apparent look like Cheetos but they're
chicken nuggets they're cheet Cheeto
chicken nuggets let me tell you they're
already sold out can't even find them
anywhere orange as the sun beautiful in
the glow of the night orange orange
orange orange Cheeto chicken nuggets
Cheeto Cheeto chicken nuggets there so
oh boy okay who else do we have on bonan
of the week oh yes Eric Trump Eric Trump
and we were talking
about is that how he talked is that I
don't know I was like what's a weird I
mean you can make an you can make like
I'm a dummy uh kind of voice but I was
like I'm Eric Trump oh no I'm Eric Trump
and I'm gonna I don't know I mean I've
done the whiny baby Eric Trump before
and right we've actually Eric Trump on
the show if no one has seen
if you go to the Trump if you go to the
parody um it was actually when he was
testifying believe it or not are doing
his deposition for this case is the
reason why he came on the show is when
he counted all the way up to 500 right
and he got to 500 and then he was like
no why not some more and then he gave
500 I plead the fifths here's his sister
um testifying a court now this is a this
is the internet producing it's a time
machine I I guess the internet has a
flux cap cador and it goes into the
future takes pictures in the courtroom
and then sends them back uh as her
testifying here this is now what's the
story I know Eric testified yesterday
and he perjured himself twice apparently
he said he said he said on the show I
don't know what financial statements are
and then he's like like did you ever
work I think the question was did you
ever work for the Trump org and he's
like no I don't I don't recall and
they're like okay here's an email from
like 2013 right when you when you
responded with your email from the Trump
org about the Trump Borg I mean these I
mean I I said it uh I think I said it on
your show but I also said it on my show
which was like Don Jr and Eric Trump are
going to do whatever they can to please
their father and as a result they're
going to
reveal issues for their own case right
they're going to go up there and be like
oh well no I didn't know that or it was
just the it was just the financial
people the accountants that's what I pay
them for which has many people
questioning well then what did you ever
do at the Trump organization like you
both are senior level Executives at the
Trump or what the [__] did you do if you
had no idea about the deals the
contracts the licensing agreements
Financial
condition what you were in charge of
then and that's what your role was but
you're telling us that you just left it
for the experts to do then what did you
actually do at your job well here's
six-fingered Eric Trump this seems to be
a theme with the trumps they have six
fingers see how he's got five fingers in
the thumb here this is him I gotta ask I
gotta ask I want to know for small rat
was that on purpose or was that the the
our you know this is this is not that
well hang on a second hang on a say I
think you're making accusations here
this is not this is not Ai No this is
not AI this is real oh okay
oh I'm trying to give you a new a new
theory of mine is that the the Trump
family yeah yeah he did ple the six I
plead the sixth but but this is a thing
the Trump family this is a secret
they're hiding see ivanka's finger or
hand here she has is that the
constitution or the Declaration of
Independence what is it no that's that's
called an Indulgence apparently an
Indulgence um in in Catholic history you
could buy an Indulgence you could buy at
your right to commit a crime so it's
like a but she's Jewish now why would
she have it well I mean you know we're
not also Catholic when were they ever
Catholic I don't know this is just again
these are weird things that we find on
the internet that are real that are 100%
real I honestly thought it was the
Declaration of Independence and I was
like yes we're getting our [__]
National Treasure 3 movie it's happening
Real Time with
six-fingered yeah they're like look she
one two three four five and she's got a
thumb here on the opposite theong here's
what I'll say here's what I'll say you
know some people like to call it a five
finger discount but for the trumps they
like to throw an extra one in there okay
and that's called a six-finger discount
yeah that's a special one that's why
that's the conspiracy it's a six-finger
conspiracy for the trumps and they like
to hide it every once in a while what
they like to do Gabe is they like to put
out AI images like this one this is an
AI image of trump Eric Trump outside the
court you can see he has he has five
fingers in this one this one clearly is
fake because he only has the five
fingers yeah clearly clearly what would
you say clearly you do here
clearly you playing I'm not playing say
you do
here
you what exactly would you say you do
here I'm a people person I'm a I I deal
with people I deal with people I'm gonna
have to I'm gonna have to throw that
into a what was that yeah there you go
well there's no way get that sound in
the just like just like uh there are so
many good there's so many good clips
that come from uh I think you should
leave with Tim Robinson and there's one
specifically where he's like you sure
about that are you sure and Liz
Harrington the spokesperson for Donald
Trump was like there's no case against
uh in Georgia there's no case all these
people are pleading guilty it's like you
sure about that you sure about
that because really that's what it is
like these people are denying to like I
never worked at this company I never saw
those documents I don't know this person
my son who are they this lawyer that I
signed and publicly tweeted about I have
no idea what you're talking about well
you know it's almost like they don't
know who these people are like marjerie
Taylor green doesn't know what an
insurrection is which leads me to my
Alpha oh yes Marjorie Taylor green um
you know we were Marine yeah the petti
yeti actually you know what I've got I
got um again I've got some images here
of marer Taylor green um and she just
can't put the shovel down and matter of
fact she's got a haul in the backo here
uh for for this here I believe I believe
the pety yeti is just like many people
are like oh oh look you were born with
like an extra appendage or something
right like oh that's a weird mutation uh
marjerie Taylor green just has a shovel
and a
rake just it's like grown into her body
oh you know it's already part of her
okay well I
[Music]
mean that's not a bad tune I'm not going
to lie the petty ye it's a catchy tune
with the shovel back yeah it's a catchy
little a hoe a back ho back ho oh back
ho back that's that's not not like not
she is a hoe backo but tell us why tell
us why the the backo lady why this backo
is on the alpha cook well tell us why
she's the alpha cook exactly well last
night I believe it was last night she's
on the house floor and she's making a
big [__] deal about yeah
uh uh melting down statues stat the
statues remember if anyone remembers the
statues you know the one that caused the
Charlottesville Riot the one where they
were fine people on both sides according
to Trump right the people that uh Tommy
tuberville would totally call Americans
you know because he has called white
nationalists Americans and those are the
ones he wants sering in the military but
we're on the house floor and she
believes that it was uh Roberty Lee is
the founding father and she made this
state and I I kid you not we got video
of it we got video she said that Robert
Lee you know founding
father and then the facts get checked
real time well here's what I want to say
because I'm going to play the clip here
well maybe I'll just play the clip and
then I'll I'll tell you what I actually
think the Founding Father thing is about
but let's watch let's watch the clip
here let's watch her get cucked why this
is the Democrat and the Biden
administration's effort to erase our
history just as they have done to the
Statue of Robert E Lee yeah this is an
outrage outrage so just to clear up a
couple of things my mentioned the
founding fathers Robert ele was not
actually one of the funding fathers he
was a general of the Confederacy that
was okay so so um that's one thing one
point is that he was the general of the
Confederacy but it's like two different
time periods in history like way like
there's a few years in between the
founding of the nation and and then and
then the Civil War like Roberty Lee's
dad may have been born when the founding
fathers were almost dead right like like
like this is two separate times in our
history like these are two
I mean we're we're talking you know cuz
like Robert Lee died in 1870 right and I
don't know it's almost like there's a
number that Republicans always like to
talk about Lauren bobbert even said this
is our what' you say oh 1776 that's
right on on January 6 she said that so
if he died in
1870 and the founding fathers were
working on a document around
1776 he clearly was 150 years old when
he died in 1870 clearly clearly clearly
clearly our founding fathers uh
are they transcend time and space and
they're able to be both on the B fory
but also on the signing grounds right of
of uh of of important
establishing documents to our country I
think you're missing an important fact
here the important fact here is that the
founding fathers not only founded our
country but they invented the flux
capacitor that's that's the thing this
would be the same one that helps us
right now getting these images exactly
exactly same same exact thing so but but
let's let's hear why Roberty Lee wasn't
a founding father because everyone know
he was he had a flux capacitor for
crying out loud the city of
Charlottesville that wasn't a national
monument that when that statue was
removed and I I just have to say uh I
find it rich that the party that has
supported book Banning in our
libraries um rewriting curriculum not
talking about our history over and over
again is the very one that is saying
that we have to often keep painful
monuments in places where they do damage
where they interfere with people's
ability to enjoy the particular area
that they're in and leave it to the
Department of interior to have that
discretion so if we're going to get into
talking about book Banning and rewriting
history let let's have an honest debate
about it and talk about the differences
between our two parties on this I oppose
this amendment and I yell
back well not only not not not only that
but there's another point that I want to
bring up is like the same party who
talks about we're a constitutionalist we
love the Constitution man First
Amendment Second Amendment Fifth
Amendment all those other
ones oh God they love to say how how
they're they're experts and they love to
claim that their party is the is the
founding party that put it all together
and when you
realize that not only are they trying to
ban books but they would benefit from
Reading those books hey easy easy no no
I'm not gonna hold I'm not gonna hold up
on this one I'm not hold on this one
easy you're saying they're gonna read is
that what you're saying look even even
give me [__] to speech give me an
audio book I don't give a [__] put these
kids back in the you know I don't know
what track of school they're on it's
clearly not the fast one but when you
look at the books that they want to ban
they want to rewrite they want to say
this and and not only that but you would
think that if they're going to rewrite
history that they would at least get the
facts right they would at least get the
timeline well here's what I think you're
missing okay here's what I think you're
missing is that margorie Taylor green is
referring to Robert E Lee as a founding
father of her government and her
preferred uh Confederacy that's right he
was a founding father of the Confederacy
and we know that margorie Taylor green
loves the Confederacy she's always
talking about she's always talking about
a divorce of the nation she's always
talking about how she would she would
love to live in the the real America the
real America I think she may be talking
about the Confederacy and that he's a
founding father of the confeder
maybe she believes that she's been
elected to the house of delegates for
the Confederacy I don't in my in my mind
right now I have this moment playing out
where margorie Taylor green is writing
with her pen pal and that pen pal is who
she believes to be Roberty Lee and he's
like dearest margarine scratch that
Dearest margerie I'm here on the
Battlefront supporting our rights our
state's
rights W we're going to win this war
because W is right
love Le dear dear dear it's kind of like
it's kind of like the trucker Convoy
yeah dear dear dear but I can I can
easily I can easily or see her writing
she's like dear dearest Roberty Lee my
little Bobby I can't wait to see you
when you come back from fighting all
those illegals down at the
[Laughter]
dear dear dear Robbie boy dear Bobby
Robbie my sweet lob
slob because you know that she's a freak
like that she's like oh yeah
or the sex guru stuff is yes that is and
then and then uh I see this comment here
which is Colin says Gabe he didn't have
teeth so I guess he' sound like this
there is my
I'm here riding to you from the southern
border these illegals keep coming after
me trying to steal my stuff damnos
stealing my candy in Halloween
too oh my God I could easily see them
right back and forth or just margory
writing to herself in a mirror and she's
like I wonder what Robbie Lobby slobby
would say to me Robbie Robbie Bobby
Lobby slobby yeah that's his name that's
his name officially now from now on
Robert E Lee you deem that speaking
speaking of
slobby um the dishonorable mention this
week is micro
Jenson micro Johnson
Miguel micro
[Music]
Johnson small W energy micro
Johnson
that's what we do here on the Tony
Michaels podcast we like to have fun so
there's small energy what what happened
why is he did dishonorable mention what
happened to M [__] little [__] fell on
his face oh yeah we have do we have a
video of that because I would love to
have a video of uh I don't have video
but maybe there's a there's a little rat
in the lab that could work up a little
some something not saying he can I'm
just saying he an image here but
but mikro
Johnson uh found himself in a position
this week where he was like I'm the new
speaker and I'm going to do whatever I
want and I'm going to come after the IRS
and try to defund it but I'm also going
to try to push away the funding for
Ukraine so 14.3 billion dollar ain't
going to go to Ukraine it a it's it's
not gonna go right it's it's just
like Israel Ukraine the IRS these are
the things that these people decided to
put in in
the
in in I guess in the wings of of getting
cut and getting threatened and weakened
uh and so Mike Johnson was like I'm
gonna pull a fast one and then it's
going to go to the Senate which is going
to be dead on arrival and the
president's already threatened to veto
everything Mike Johnson's doing yeah
it's just like the Wiener of the house
has definitely got small wiener energy
I'm not going to lie he's going to and
then we come to a government shutdown
and the only person that is to blame
is the Republicans because they're the
ones who are trying to and and the other
thing too it comes back to this whole
idea of like
hiring IRS agents over the next 10 years
right over 10 years is what the the uh
IRS wanted to do to fill the gaps of
retiring employees and
then hire new people in train them but
Republicans want you to think that
there's going to be an IRS agent that's
going to kick down your door and he's
going to come after you yeah but really
it's because they don't want the IRS
auditing I don't know people who are
benefiting financially from tax
loopholes and uh being billionaires who
may or may not be donating to certain
people's campaigns or I don't know
buying uh certain people uh like Supreme
Court justice as if they were a
collectible uh you know an nft like
Clarence Thomas clearence Thomas because
he's on sale but this always on sale
thank you Mike Johnson for making your
debut as dishonorable mention uh but
also being the wiener of the
house the of House
[Music]
Johnson bow yeah Mike Johnson making his
debut as the winner of the house and on
dishonorable mention now BR brings us to
our winner for bone end of the week GES
hinches Tommy two branches tuberville
Tommy tuille you know you know what I
thought I thought his name was
tuberville this whole time yeah and it's
actually tuberville really yeah which is
dumb because a tub would be two bees
typically tuber tuber tuber tuberville
that's why it's tuberville yeah it's
it's it's tuber not
tuber Tommy tuberville it's terville you
see see I I I I think I think the
government is the government and the
government shouldn't be government but
see if we don't do the government then
the military has the government thing
and then what it should be is the
military thing should do government but
it shouldn't do government because
government bad even though I'm into
government and government
goody sound nobody is more military than
me okay no one is more military than me
okay I never even served in the goddamn
military but no one's more military than
me that's why no more mil no one's more
military than him is because he and you
have to ask oh what's your experience
Tommy tuberville and he goes well I was
a football coach right I see I see
during during my time throwing around
Pig SK skins with them boys to colleges
you know where they get smart and stuff
that's that's where I learned the
military but it's also where I learned
the government because government bad
you know we don't want a government what
this is literally how he sounds this
that's how he sounds most you can take
the boy out of Alabama but you can't
take the Alabama out of the boy well
yeah it's funny because he actually is
out of Alabama he lives in Florida did
you know that he lives in Florida he
lives in
Florida this [__] lives in
Florida but let's listen to Tommy uh
this is just yesterday talking about
government and stuff some of these
people have some of these people have
multiple have doing multiple jobs some
of these military personel even the
Marine Corps coment was doing two jobs
why aren't you making it harder for them
to to do their job 200000 people to work
for him okay so uh and as somebody said
he's working 18 hours a day Jack Reed
blamed me for his heart attack come on
give me a break this guy's G give me a
break 20 hours a day no matter what
that's what we do you know I years
because you got to get the job wait I'm
sorry I'm sorry stop that stop that stop
that he did it for years for years a
football coach for year he worked fo
coach 20 listen Gabe when you're doing
government it's like football see when
you're doing football you do football 18
hours a day and let me tell you
something about footballing in
government when you government the
football and then you football the
government it's it's a wild thing
because that's just what we do that's
what we do down Alabama even though I
live even though I live in Florida
that's what we do in Alabama is because
we football and the government and the
government does the football that's how
I mean you go 18 20 hours a day man you
got Alabama Shakes that's where you get
man Alabama Shakes you shake shake shake
shake shake shake shake shake shake for
18 20 hours man I got to tell you man
your bum is sore not from the dancing
not from the working but from the other
stuff that we don't like to
condone um you thought George W Bush was
stupid
like even [__] I can't even fathom it
I I us think like this is the dumbest
person on the planet that we ever
elected me once shame on you fool me
twice
won't get shamed again I'm get not gonna
happen again not gonna happen again uh
it Miss mission accomplished my mission
accomplished DOD one thought you had me
uh I will give I will give George Bush
credit he was able to dodge a shoe do
you think do you think Tu do you think
Tommy Tu branches be able to dodge you
you see me Dodge a shoe I'm telling you
when I dodge a shoe that's a it's man no
one Dodge a shoe better than me I mean
those shoes College cleats those things
are sharp man wor cut your eye open man
I've worked 20 hours a day 20 hours a
day before come on man 20 hours a day
Dam what 20 20 hours a day 20 hours a
day is what I work to dodge shoes that
that way in case I ever George Bush I
have to die to shoe because government
and stuff I'll tell you this government
stuff Gabe this government stuff it's a
it's got the military in it and it's the
government and it's this government is
hard it's hard to govern you got to get
hey I'm just saying I'm saying the
important thing about ball is I mean
well really the important thing about
military and everything you know the US
military they no one's more military
than me you gotta remember the five DS
of dodgeball okay you gotta Dodge duck
dip dive Dodge okay five DS a dodgeball
very important when you work in the
military okay 18 20 hours a day you gota
work yourself down to Bone okay and I'm
just saying oh tell me what come on man
he's gonna be working 1820 he's got
2,000 people out there come on
man give that [__] so you thought
you thought Tommy tuberville was stupid
you just pointed out something to me
that I didn't know Jenna Ellis is dumber
is dumber than Tommy tuberville here's
Jen Ellis Justin Hart pointed this
ladies and gentlemen Gavin Newsome of
course he's joking right this is the uh
no no they really thought this was Gavin
Newsome yes Justin hars this [__]
stupid dude Justin Jus godamn Justin I
actually I actually thought Justin
wasn't this [__] dumb no no no no no
let he's this [__] dumb yeah because
hold on hold on hold I'll find I'll find
that correction so you read the tweet
and then I'll find the uh the correction
here's here's Justin now now this is a
video of Tommy duberville falling down
the the airplane stairs which happens it
can happen to the best of us and it
couldn't have happened to a nicer guy
here but apparently Justin Hart thought
this was Gavin Nome and then Jenna Ellis
bought it too this dude really wants to
be Biden so bad these people are so
[__] dumb either that or they think
people are dumb if they think this was
[__] Gavin Newsome what the [__] you
got be kiding me it's CRA okay so here's
the here's the correction tweet that he
made after wait wait wait he [__] up
and then he admitted it yeah I know I
dude first time for everything I gotta
tell you I gotta tell you surely not so
so Justin Hart Who we've encountered in
those Mario Twitter spaces um you know
99% of the time I'm like you're a
[__] idiot and I don't agree with you
there is a off chance and I'm like oh
you actually made a point weirdly enough
but most of the time it's the fact that
he's wear he's making just dumb points
so this video he posts a video and goes
Gavin Newsome everybody which is you
know what's funny about that you know
whose video that he he
took it's from midest touch yeah so they
shared that clip of him falling right
Tommy superville this this is the Tik
Tok and it is tagged minus touch and he
brought it down he's like Gavin Nome and
then every one was like look man you're
an idiot you're even people on the on
the right after they had shared it
around like oh man got me again people
on the right were like wait that's not
that's not Gavin Nome that's Tommy
tuberville
and the and then I saw Jenna Ellis and I
was like oh yes [__] yes Jenna Ellis
share that tweet you [__] idiot
because here's the thing Jenna Ellis
would and I said in my tweet I was like
not only is she an incompetent lawyer
but she's also
a guilty a
guilty uh seditionist she admitted she's
guilty she admitted to fault and she
took a lesser charge for admitting her
uh her involvement in trying to overturn
the election results in
Georgia and so not only is she dumb as a
lawyer and as guilty and admitted
herself and wrote a letter and cried
about it those little crocodile tears of
hers and admitted to her wrongdoing in
said
a coup she's also dumb as [__] rocks
in general because she thought Gavin
knew some fell down the stairs not
knowing that it was actually their own
republican from the Senate Tommy T
tuberville what's funny is Justin says I
deleted a post where I was told so
someone told him it was Gavin so he just
assumed it was falling down a flight of
stairs it was actually Senator
tuberville apologies what are you
apologizing for are you apologizing that
you fell for it are you apologizing that
you got it wrong are you apologizing
that it was
a this is like when Seth Abramson yeah
came after me and told his 900,000
followers that they should all block me
because he fell for a joke on a trump
post that I made because he as a
journalist didn't do his research and he
just took it at face value didn't even
look into it didn't even go to truth
social where it said it was from and
people like that who play victim and
then blame others for their own
mistakes no [__] them that's what I say
[__] him and and you know what you know
what here's the thing [__] Tommy
tuberville [__] Tom [__] two two
branches Tommy and govern hey look Gabe
government's hard okay and when you got
hard stuff you just what you got to do
is you got have good offense and a good
defense fend off stuff this hard and
government this government stuff is it's
real hard and when you throw the
military into this stuff cuz I'm I'm the
most military person you've ever seen in
your life I'm telling you no one's more
military than me no one's more military
to me no one and this government
military stuff it's hard it's hard stuff
and you got to work 18 20 hours a day
because I used to work 18 20 hours a day
now that I'm a senator I don't work at
all I I honestly harlon hitner pays me
all the money to say this stupid [__] he
pays me all kinds of money we go down
there we we read his sign copy of my
conf it's best book I've ever seen in my
life oh man it's way better than the
Bible so much better in the Bible that
signed copy of mcom oh man I've seen it
in his Li have you ever seen a library
before they got libraries at
universities Li liary library library I
believe I believe it's a group I used I
used to teach the football at a college
and they had they had libraries they had
libraries I never went to them but they
had libraries you know some sometimes
when my lady when my lady goes to the
market on Sunday she get she picks up
some Li berries oh my she pick up some
Liber they're juicy they are
juy I I I you can read at library but
the best thing to do is eat liary pie
Library oh man my
mama yeah man people talk about
strawberry rubar man it's all about that
liberry rubar pie okay oh [__] Tommy
duberville I'm so glad you're Bonet of
the week because you're such a [__]
Bonet in general Gabe Sanchez Bonet of
the week Senator Tommy Tu bench
tuberville let's give him his
[Music]
[Applause]
due two of the biggest [__] Bon heads
ever Eric Trump and Tommy tuberville and
he [__] ran away with it did you see
that Eric wasn't even close to Tom he
got I think when I did the numbers he
was like at 6%
yeah like six and some change and then
uh oh no sorry yeah sorry George Santos
is like eight something and then Eric
Trump was like six something or it might
have been flipped I forget which one and
then Tommy TR was like 86 85% something
like
that poor Tommy two branches poor Tommy
do you remember that when he first got
elected Senator he couldn't he couldn't
name but two branches the government
he's like yeah there's the see there's
government and it's kind of like
football you got offense you got defense
so you got the you got the you got the
Congress that thing and then you got and
you got the White House you got those
two branches right there like offense
and defense that's that's what that's
what you play in the government and in
the football is offense and defense
don't go anywhere this has been bone of
the week stick around we got some
announcements right after
[Music]
[Applause]
this